the lay prodigy and his protege have
returned but why mere days after it was
reported that Disney and Sony failed to
reach an agreement to establish new
terms of the deal to be a part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe spider-man
himself pay two visits one of the most
beloved Marvel actors out there Tom
Holland the man at the center of the
Disney Sony debacle and Iron Man star
Robert Downey jr. were hanging out
together on August 22nd just two days
after the world learned that spider-man
will be leaving the MCU to remain sole
property of Sony Pictures Holland took
to Instagram to share a series of snaps
of himself and Downey jr. together she
had in a carousel pose to Holland's 30
million followers on the platform
three of the four photos show the two
men on a hike they smile at the camera
and one shot pull some silly faces and
another and flex her muscles and scowled
in the third the final picture in the
collection is perhaps the funniest of
all it shows Holland and Downey jr. in a
house playing with spider-man and Iron
Man action figures Holland's seen
holding one of the armored Avenger
while Downey jr. is flashing a wide grin
at the camera and holding a spider-man
toy up to his face to top it all off
holland caption the photo set worth we
did it mr. stark which sure sounds
familiar you did it
thus an innocent enough caption it's
just Holland's witty way of saying that
Ian Downey jr. completed what was
probably a grueling hike in the summer
heat and these are innocent enough
photos they show two actives who have
become friends off-screen spending a day
in sunny California getting some fresh
air and letting loose a little
however given recent events some fans
are convinced that these photos and
Holland's caption means that the two
actors may have received some good news
about Spidey status in the MCU the
comments section of Holland's post are
filled with speculative statements like
the idea that Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige Ranga Holland told him
Disney and Sony went back to the
negotiating table and agreed to let
spider-man back into Marvel's movie
world and had him meets up with Downey
jr. to celebrate others seem to believe
that Holland and Downey jr. may have had
a sit-down discussion with Disney and/or
Sony executives about the spider-man
madness and thereafter hiked selfies
were meant to tease at the meeting
yielded great results now we don't know
the intimate details of Hollins and
Downey juniors lives but it's difficult
to believe that the real reason why the
two were hanging out right now has much
to do with spider-man's recent departure
from the MCU the interesting thing here
though is why Holland and Downey jr.
were in the same place Holland's
recently said on Instagram that he was
going back to work after apparently
taking some time off
and since Hollywood is the epicenter of
the entertainment industry it makes
sense for Holland going back to work
means heading to California
surely Holland and Downey jr. would make
time to hang out on the youngster
touched down in Tinseltown no matter
what considering they have a genuine
friendship but the two were actually
working on a project together Universal
Pictures Doolittle based on who loved
ings 1922 book the voyages of dr.
Doolittle the film features Downey jr.
as dr. John Dolittle and Holland as the
voice of a dog named chip since the
flick is set for release in January 2020
it stands to reason on the caster's in
California
finishing up filming who do the talkin
Enterprise production in time for a
theatrical launch so there you have it
Holland and Downey jr. are probably
spending time together because they've
wrapped up Dolittle not because they
executed a secret plan to storm the
offices of Sony Pictures and a man that
the studio squash its beef with Disney
and Marvel so Spider Man can stick
around the MCU
though the timing makes it seem this way
more at play and Holland's cheeky
caption only adds more fuel to the fires
of speculation the great Holland Downey
jr. hangout set of 2019 is likely or
down to do little and if it isn't well
Marvel fans have a big storm coming
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel under
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]